Toddler having followed diarrhea today after eating sand yesterday. What could I do to support the digestion through this?
Sometimes the best thing you can do honestly is to let it pass. So
I'd be more concerned if your toddler ate sand and then they were constipated.
Then you'd want to do things to help remove that. Sometimes when you understand it, you get sick and you
are vomiting. Sometimes the way that we have been taught through the medical system is that we got to stop
this vomiting. So we're going to give this person a Tylenol. We're going to give this person
to decrease the fever. My child has a fever. So I'm going to give him Tylenol to decrease the
fever. Yes, I've decreased the fever. I've solved the problem. Actually, you probably made the problem
much worse. The body caused this increased fever state to go off and get infection. The body is
causing you to expel your stomach contents to deal with it infection. So you're
expeling your stomach contents. Now, of course, there's limits to how high a fever you want to get
and there's limits to a person having just explosive vomiting that is uncontrollable. Same thing with
diarrhea. You have to get to the root of things. Same thing with diarrhea. The person's got diarrhea
and you can pinpoint it to the AIDS sand. Maybe it was just the irritation of the sand,
the silicone or whatever that's in that sand or the rocks that's in there,
that they're expeling that. It's a good thing that they're expeling that. So if you can all start to
think that way a little better of why the body is doing this, it can give us more clues to
what's going on and it can give us more clues to maybe this is a good thing that's going on.